How will you inspire the minds of many?
Will you provide new perspective...
...that will allow others to see...
...a world full of opportunities?
Will you create a voice that captures the imagination of a kingdom?
Will you share a welcoming smile that has others feel like royalty?
Will you bring the world together via the speed of sound...
...or the hush of a jungle?
Will a rich culture and the arts become the fabric of your attendees?
Will you stimulate their senses with cuisine envied by the world?
Will you forever change the definition of a meeting room...
...and inspire creativity in the beauty of silence?
Will you redefine the meaning of work-life balance...
...and create a venue that will have attendees feeling forever connected?
Create the moments that inspire the minds of many.
Connect people.
Inspire the world.
Thailand.